M: Oh, sorry, I'm not ready
B: *whispered slightly* Fucking nerd.
M: I know
B: Goddamn
M: You guys like my skin? Pretty cool right?
B: Dude, default boy
B: I mean default-
M: Excuse- excuse you
B: default human.
M: I actually identify as an alien...
B: Do you do the the clicky thing when you stalk people and do you like-
M: oh  I've gotta shove so much inside of everybody's holes
B:Oh hell yeah
M: Hell yeah
B: that sounds fun
M:Thank you. It is. For me...
B: Yeah, no, it sounds fun. Exclusively for you.
M: I was expecting a lot more enemies to be here.
M: Surprisingly-
B:I found one!
B:if you want to make sick plays There's like a whole shit ton of uh, impulses down there.
M: Naw I'm okay
I'm not good enough to do sick plays... Actually, you know what, scratch that I'm gonna, I'm gonna grab some of those.
B: i know you wanna make some sick plays.
M: Dude, I'm gonna make the sickest plays.
B: So sick that you might die while making them.
M: No, you don't know that. That's not (burp), guaranteed...
B: Okay Rick... Thanks...
M: Hmmmm morbo...
B: Laughs
M: We gotta go to the mmmmmm thing, Morbo...
M: I don't know...
B: Thats a cross over...
M: I've never seen the show
B: Listen Morbo... destroyer of worlds...
M :Laughs
B: Ugh, listen
M: Oh, don't worry, I'll miss every shot...
M: Every shot will miss...
B: Alright, this is where the aggressive building comes in...
M: Oh oh kay (laughs)...
B: OHH! I got the double d knock...
M: Boink!
M: I am in uhh... trouble
B (in the background): You know what, I need a door... Unable to edit?! This is not...
M: Oh God, I got in trouble, ah, there were two of them I've got sc- Ohohohooo
M: Don't go back there...
M: You can do this. He has no idea.
M: There you go
B: HAHAAAAAA!
B: The last shot...
B: DIE
M: Dude, I'm real proud of you, but it seems like our team might lose this one...
M: I'd like to think that if I made my pro move a little bit better, it would have worked out for us but...
Alas...
I'm terrible...
B:The blue is coming...
B: I'm gonna die to the blue... Its gonna happen...
M: That's your favorite thing to do
B: Hah, Hah!
B: Li- Wha
B: What the fuck!! You can do it John Wick!
M: No John Wick's a real...Oh that. Nope. B: It's John Wick! Please
Okay, thank you Oh, give me that give no no
B: No, I wanna live! No I wanna live!
M: Set a sweet trap, set a trap!
Do it!! Pro move...
B: I did it. Oh no I didn't have any! No I clicked. Why didn't you plaaace?
B: Alright well, I feel like that one's on me.
I mean I feel like we should've won this one
M: I feel like - B: they have those fucking down - M: yeah that was entirely your fault
B: Maybe standing in the open wasn't the play, Dammit
M: Maybe me trying to sneak up on two people with a shotgun from a hundred meters away wasn't the best idea
B: Ah... you know... It happens
M: For some reason It only happens to me!!
I don't know. Maybe maybe maybe I'm stupid. Maybe I'm the bad one. No, that can't be it. It's Impossible
Why aren't we on the bus five seconds, man? Calm your boobs. Come on. Hurry up. What is this PUBG? Let's Go!
Your Boobs are so uncalm right now.
This is gonna be funky.
OoOoO Tilted circle.
Uh Oh, Uhuhu, Uhuhuh no
I see that. -I'm gonna crawl up in here behind you if you want to swear it back for me
All right, like literally build a ramp up, right here? Oh, I see
I see I see. I see I see I see yo right now I got you
Yeah dude, check out all of my money's I
Spend them on that sweet
sssweet stuff I definitely need I
I didn't see him. I heard the whoosh he can't hit me if I'm dead
I think he got me man. No
I'm gonna go on my own terms, bye world
B: Well, that was fun. M: Was it really? we didn't win, it can't be fun.
Oh, boy
T: I kinda want to head to Retail, and then move in.
M: Okay
Easy enough for me. I was- because I was about ready to go to Tilted
I'm like, well, it's gonna be a short round for me. But thanks for saving me from myself
T: They just got revived- M: Oohoohoo
Sorry, I threaded a really cool needle it was awesome it was so sick and legit
T: I literally had a guy break down my ramp and rebuild the ramp to a
To a chest and take the chest from me just now
well
Maybe you should get better and stop letting people
yeet on you. That's not the right word
T: Yeet?
Yeah, you know, you know when you get yeet'd on?
B: When you got that yeet?
When someone yeets all over you? Oh wow our team's already 10 up, how does that even happen?
T: Hacks. M: No, I don't think that's a valid reason you can't just blame everything on hacks, man
T: Well... uh... M: (mocking) Uh, uh- T: ...they... won?
I mean yep, yeah, you know what
Can't argue with that flawless logic
According to Tyler. Uh 10 down plus our team. How do- They won. They got it good.
T: They got good and won that.. that.. shoot. M: Yep Tyler, yeah that's.. (laughing)
T: I got 3 hours of sleep last night and I'm pretty tired.
M: (mocking) A'm prutty tired.
Oh no! No! No! No, mine! God damnit!
Fuck you. T: It's me!
I Know. fuck you, I was still there. that doesn't mean it's okay. Oh, don't worry. I'm stealing your chest
We're friends. that makes it worse!
Knocked him.
Woah- crash? God fucking damn it every time! God damn this game.
Anyway, I'm not there anymore. T: I'll let you know when and if I get this crossbow kill. 'Cause I know you're dying to hear about it.
Mm and I'm gonna I'm gonna make a faithful recreation of whatever the hell is going on in your game.
T: Are you just drawing?
No, I've got you. T: Oh! I'm dead. M: Already?
Oh man, but I don't even get to make my- I was gonna make an artistic recreation of you. Dude
you don't even know what I was making it was gonna be so good look, ah shit. Oh, it's you
T: I like how you're just telling me, I can't SEE it.
No, no, no, no, it's good, it's good. It's you you've got a sweet Scar coming out of this bush here and
There's like, hang on, we need a Fortnite background. Oh wait, I got this.
Okay, so you're here and there's people everywhere
Swooping in on y'all swoopty-yeet style
[Mark imitating battle noises and screaming] "Stop right there criminal scum!" And you're like
"Oh! Oh! Oh! bang bang bang bang" [Tyler laughing]
"Boom boom boom boom boom boom" and then "Hohoho got 'em" and then all of you with your gun
Gotta run gotta run gotta run gotta run gonna run. And then this guy comes up behind you. Whoops. Oh, hang on
This guy comes up. He's like "Stop right there, where do you- where do you think you're going?" and then all of a sudden
Pew! Pew! Pew!
Uh.. Pwink, pwink, pwink!
there goes your bush and now you're dead oops, no, no, what you're dead. wait, hang on
[death noises] [fart sound]
There we go, alright that was my faithful recreation of whatever the hell you were just doing
Alright, oh god dammit, of course I go on the side that doesn't have an entrance. Oh no, no, no. No, but I wanted this
T: Somebody land next to you?
No, they- I didn't land on the roof of this place and they did, so
Why-? The fucking
What the- oh fuck you! They frickin- are you fucking kidding me? Fuck you! Fuck you!
I've never had more anger in my veins. All right, whatever. Let's just get this-
I have no ammo 'cause I wasted it all shooting that guy
Oh! hit you didn't knock you though don't know how I didn't knock you come on give me those sweet sweet knocks
Come on, give me the knocks
Yes, finally got a knock
T: had a guy right in front of me, I had the crossbow... sights in my.. vision!
That's how you say that
Yeah, that is the way that is the will and that is the way of that. Knock him. Hehheh
Well, that's another for me and to prove how great I am there you go job dad bill dude, oh
All right. I'm ready if you're ready. I'm ready. I'm near you
Nice you're near me hell yeah
That is what friends are. That's what I need. That's what a lot of people tell me sadly
There's only so much me to go around
I found a ammo box where a toilet should be...
Yeah, That seems about right I always like to make sure I've got my bullets near where I shit it's my most vulnerable moment so
They're probably all in
That's not very nice
Got'em
Are they assumed to be siblings? What?
You said they're in my mom!
No they're not. You know what, you got me you reversed the got. I thought I had you turns out I was mistaken
You really switched that burn around
Someone stick heed my boy
Miss me miss me missed. Yes. No, no, no, no, no, dude. I'm nailing you. I'm nailing
dude
Every shot no misses dude. I'm so good at this game. Bomba. Don't boom Shope wampa don't bump will bump
couch that is TJ's making this couch
Was gonna cast a spell
he's gonna lace the bonds of ownership all over he's gonna make sure the
Sanctimony is not breached. Oh, I guess sweet impulse grenade. You're about to see the sweetest action that you've ever seen in your life
Not him never mind not eating not eating eating is not having I'm stuck in her
curtain first word Burton Burton help help
There they're all up in here off fucking poor sight
God damn it. Yeah, they came up in hard and fast
Dude that's rude man do this mean are you gonna be like that? Always a way to mom joke, it's always a wait mom
There hasn't been a mom joke since 2014
We've been clean since then. Oh
You've ruined it. You've soiled it. Alright, one more one more. Don't miss me too much. I'll be there
Well, I don't plan to die this round I've made a commitment I'm actually gonna be good this time
Alright, nevermind. I ran straight into a tree and couldn't go anywhere meet. Yo eat. Okay, and
See I'm sayin, it's normally like why what's wrong with me it's yeah, it's been a recent thing
I've started doing it as a joke. And then all the sudden is you dog get the heat and I can't stop me
I see it. I'm gonna try to I'm gonna fuck them up or all of my shots are gonna miss
Yep any shot I need that crossbow killed
Knock-down
Sorry, oh no, I didn't know you were that guy. All right. I'm reviving you
Don't worry, buddy. Good
You're dead again I'm dead again
I'm gonna die aren't I I'm gonna die or night. I'm gonna die. Oh, yeah here I go
Oh, oh, oh, I'm out of materials. Oh boy. They're after me. They're after me
They're after me. I can't
boertie for it save me
I don't trust going in a porter for them to go stay to the side of the border
Whoa, who the fuck? Try me? Try me? Try me? Try me. Oh boy. Oh, wow! Oh
Damn it. Why me? Why me? Why me help please? Help John wick, please
Teammates, you fucking assholes!
All right, anyway I'm out. fuck this shit so stupid this games stupid and all the developers are terrible
Maybe
Goodbye and you too